foreign
[Music]
Lord's podcast
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Ty's twinson writer
for Lords of Gaming and with me again is
Lord King
we are back with more She-Hulk and
Namaste as we revisit Emil Blonsky and
his brand new Retreat and his fancy
followers Platinum Card members and just
just a whole lot of stuff going on as
Jennifer is getting over a potential
loss of love looking gonna kick it off
to you as
kind of the same vein of last week's
episode but more of a character
development growth Arc for Jennifer in
this episode how are you feeling
oh man so getting into the episode and
they kind of left off with the guy that
she met at the wedding and you know you
and I felt that something's up with this
dude you know because it's right he was
just too good to be true to be honest
with you
and uh she gets uh nominated as female
lawyer of the year and her friend is
like wow uh this is great stuff but
I'm moving a little bit too fast so you
know they go out on a couple of dates
and they're playing the cat and mouse
thing and she actually LED some hit one
night and and and and you know you're
like you feeling good for but when she
wake up oh boy's not dead now at first I
thought he was gonna be in the kitchen
cooking right yeah I thought that too
yeah I was like uh oh he went he did
something but nah he's not there and she
texts him
and you know I'm still smiling you know
and um
you don't even have it on scene he
doesn't even hit it back like you know
give it a text back and the whole
episode she's consumed with this this
aspect of this individual not getting
back to her that who seems so interested
in her and the fact that she decided
okay I'm gonna give the cookie and you
know boom is like I think that's a
girl's worst fear to be honest with you
to really be honest with you to get
ghosted after you she did her vetting
process they went out to eat uh she
didn't kiss on the first date she didn't
sleep with him on the first date they
were having numerous text messages back
and forth he wasn't interested in how
other persona he was interested in her
so all the signals was like no lighting
up for her and
this dude leaves her on scene well now
we have the Blonsky thing because his
his PO calls her like yo
I'm having an issue you know his
inhibitor chip uh went off
we don't know what's going on with this
dude their natural fear is he does
abomination doubt and he's wreaking
havoc someplace and we gotta go check on
this dude and I can't get a SWAT team
ready so I'm calling his lawyer which is
a Hulk that's you know that and I don't
want to go to the hospital yeah cool
I'm laughing the whole time because
she's driving in her Prius and I'm like
subscribe
right she's hiding she's high on that
part right and
um
the fact is
I'm like she's a Hulk she could just
Hulk out and just you know actually jump
there you know she she doesn't have to
take this car so she's still holding on
to traditional things and she's only
using
She-Hulk as
like a like a gag feature you know and
and I'm noticing that about her life
because she has she's
insecure about She-Hulk and it will that
we'll get to that part in a second when
they get there they get to the gate and
blonsky's like yeah man
um they're talking to him and he was
like get his uh his pet his favorite
chicken uh block block was uh fluffy or
whatever was at the gate and he went
over to his electrified gate and he got
a little bit of a joke and maybe it um
did something to to the ankle bracelet
I think that's a little BS but uh I will
figure it out later but right right yeah
I'm just gonna leave that there yeah
yeah I feel like
um that Emil he has done some general
genuine stuff so far and he's been a
good guy and like Jennifer mentions you
know that oh it was just a chicken like
I it wouldn't make sense for you to work
this hard to get out jail just get back
in but there's still I want this a small
part like something something is up up
with Emile Blonsky but continue but so
now we find out that he is running this
cult type campus and we have Vibes of
that with the eight women right so once
we saw his eight soul mates that said
they was going to make sure that he is
okay and he's gonna have this Retreat so
they funneled all this money into this
Retreat that doesn't have any Wi-Fi and
Jennifer's absolutely going nuts because
she can't get a signal she's just really
harping on the fact that she's waiting
for this guy to call her back and this
guy still hasn't called the back so
before that happens before we even get
to that Park she goes out to walk to her
car because this this the the CEO of the
PO doesn't left
and man bull is out there fighting
elgardo and they trash her Prius Prime
first shout out to Marvel for having man
boo
um I believe that he debuted inside a
daredevil comic book
um and Eduardo um I I don't I don't
remember
where he debuted at but
it's pretty cool to have those two uh
fight off against each other because he
was always depicted as a matador and in
this episode he's really pissed off that
the books depict him as some form of
Matador and he's not he identifies as a
swashbuckler exactly it it's pure comedy
and then you have you know man bull
which is a joke character within himself
and they use him that way but he's these
are very strong characters they
the way they're using them
they're using them so commonplace
they're letting you know that heroes and
villains are commonplace and they are
they're people with problems but the
fact that they they trash our car
because if they're they're working out
their anger issues and Camille Blonsky
is like
um you know Namaste you know you have to
calm down with this and we need to talk
about this in the meeting and they
actually go to this Hut where they have
a circle of Peace like an AAA meeting
and they're sitting there in this circle
and uh Whatchamacallit the record comes
out of the the the the the steam Hut on
site into it and she she takes off on
him and she's you know she Hawks out on
him but we have the porcupine which is
there and he's another character
from early uh Daredevil I believe or he
could have debuted inside her book
um
but they're having this whole AAA
meeting this this uh coming to
understanding of their selves as you
know anger management type of thing and
Emile Blonsky is running this thing and
for some weird reason I'm like I'm
really not buying into it that they're
doing this but they are and they
actually help her out with her issue
with her being attached to this phone
and looking for this validation and they
get her to dig inside herself and
explain
why she's having such an issue with this
guy not texting her back and I thought
it was a it was a gut-wrenching look at
oneself and we all suffer from this
right is this something that we can
identify that we are all prison uh
prisoners of these phones right we're a
prisoner of the text back and they was
teaching her how to take back a power
and it was teaching her how to uh not be
so beholden to to the text back it was
it was a very insightful
view into the psyche of Jennifer
herself and how she views the She-Hulk
she views the She-Hulk as a cheat
because she's always been Jennifer she
works so hard to be Jennifer and so hard
to be like
and she has this cheat code now which
she can be the most popular girl that
everybody likes and everybody wants to
be around but she works so hard on Jen
and she actually found somebody that
liked Jen and now that somebody is not
texting her back so she's holding on to
that because she feels that people will
text back She-Hulk but Jen is the one
that needs the love and it was just so
warming to see
each individual even a vampire do which
is going to lead into the blade stuff
yeah
absolutely hilarious I find the whole
episode hilarious
that they're they're supporting me like
yo let's go get them let's go kill them
You Gotta Die right and
it they did you know they Blonsky was
like let's let's use the tools that we
learned here and help her with the tools
that we have in this space and I find it
freaking crazy I he almost had me
believing in it but um
the the I guess you could talk and then
we'll get to the last end credit scene
yeah which was uh revealing within
itself yeah so the cert the circle the
calming Circle therapy moment I think
shout out to Tatiana because I think
that's probably the strongest
performance I've seen her give this
entire Series so far
um a very um vulnerable vocal
performance on her part I could really
hear the strain and difficulty as she
was opening up to all these people about
a real problem that everyone can relate
to on some level
um I feel is definitely believable that
on some degree all of us have
encountered that moment of where we've
wanted to be loved or validated or given
attention at some point in our life and
when we're giving that small crumb you
know we we sneak onto like a motto flame
and for her
um after having such a high moment she
was just continually chasing that high
and then dark reality hit of where you
know homeboy is not hitting back and
happens so often in day-to-day
situations and that I think is a
strength to She-Hulk is showing even for
these individuals who were super powered
who have
um crazy good lifestyle some may seem
they still deal with everyday problems
that we can relate to
um and or for the episode
I feel that now because I believe we
only have two episodes left this is a
turning point for Jennifer of where she
is
hopefully definitely gonna solidify
herself she's reconciled
um She-Hulk and she's reconciled
Jennifer Walters that Jennifer is just
as valid as She-Hulk um and deserves
equal amounts of love
that moving forward
um hopefully we're gonna see a marriage
of those two and that she would be more
comfortable
um in her skin As She Hulk and not that
she's living a double life or cheating
in some way because now she she gave
voice to why is she so against accepting
She-Hulk it's because she felt like she
didn't deserve it she felt like she was
um short changing Jennifer by being
She-Hulk
um so hopefully uh that has been laid to
rest uh and it was fun the soundtrack
for this episode I very much enjoyed it
was good vibes some good hits some
bangers I was even jamming with her on
the car ride over
um and yeah it was a really uplifting
episode uh or most of the time that was
happening Emily even though he seemed
Shady in a different way than Josh did
um I still think you know at the end of
the day he did something good for
Jennifer and though we are not sure of
his ulterior motives I really enjoyed
Emil and the gang but not an actual gang
like just a group of people make sure
the parole officer is not an actual gang
yeah
um yeah but uh unfortunately this
episode did end with some darker
undertones as king and I were discussing
last week was confirmed we flashed back
to three days earlier from Josh's
perspective and Josh is in on the
Intelligentsia and the Hulk King and is
up to no good and he got Jennifer's
blood
that was shocking
so they were trying to get her blood as
She-Hulk and he got her blood as
Jennifer yeah and it made me think
because I was like okay if he actually
got her blood like did he unfortunately
just a bad situation of worse did he
roofie her into being in a such a deep
sleep to where she would not have woken
up because I can't imagine that you know
you're taking blood and Jennifer's just
gonna stay asleep unless she's under
some very deep she's got a bad blood
from another source as well I'm just
saying okay
that could be a possibility yeah so we
didn't she didn't wake up with no pin
prick she didn't wake up but she's a
hawk she heals fast yeah that's what I
was thinking that it could could have
been so enamored by what happened the
night prior that she didn't think of
today and then when she went to work
well it was gone just like that exactly
there's no problem as soon as he pulls
the needle while she heals automatically
anyway so as we you know show evidence
from the huge cut that she got in the in
the blood went inside and healed her an
also that she took a Titania punch to
the face this Jen it was fine but also
he scanned her phone
so now he made a clone of her phone
so he gets all her information all her
location everything that's going on with
her that's a huge uh aspect I don't know
who's working with who right I I tend to
believe the leader I think I'm gonna go
with the leader here I think the leader
is the nefarious over mind in this whole
thing
I don't know how that works with Blonsky
though because I do believe Blonsky is
in on it
because he's gaining the trust of these
super villains in having them all in
this area where and each each character
is a super villain
that they can be uh in this cult-like
mentality when it comes to Blonsky so
the allegiance will be towards the
Blonsky so it's it's it's it's it's very
weird but I believe it's the leader and
I believe he's using Blonsky and I
believe that at some point in time
there's going to be a reveal
and and we're still waiting for deer
devil I thought this was that episode
yeah I'm actually surprised there wasn't
a a jape uh fourth wall jape of her
being like
You're Expecting the pointy pointy head
one one weren't you yeah right so it's
gonna happen it's coming it's coming
so but again we are uh coming to a head
of this season I believe just two
episodes left eight and nine for
She-Hulk attorney-in-law and we just
can't wait to see how all things come to
a close
but this has been the Lord's minute
thank you so much for joining us we're
here every Monday Wednesday and Friday
at lordsagaming.net
I'm ty Swenson here with Lord King and
this has been the Lord's minute peace
[Music]